there's a lot in the ethics that's a
goldilocks argument not too hot not too
cold just right and
how do you make a rule to tell which is
which
[Music]
what is character it's like the state of
the soul that arises from the choices
one makes
state of the soul that arises from the
choices that you make
okay so we're going to try to figure out
how that works
and to do that we're going to to begin
with the beginning of book
two of the ethics and if somebody reads
the first paragraph there's some cool
stuff in there
now since virtue is of two sorts one
pertaining to thinking
and the other to character excellence of
thinking is for the most part
both in its coming to be and in its
growth a result of teaching
for which reason it has need of
experience and time
while excellence of character comes into
being as a consequence of habit
on account of which it even gets its
name by a small inflection from
habit how do you make a good choice
no simple answer right but one thing is
the motive have to do it
to do the right thing especially the
beautiful thing
you also have to estimate the
circumstances well
an act is courageous if it's done for
the beautiful
unless it's grossly foolish you can
imagine
some movie where some soldier stands up
and charges
a whole army of tanks and gets blown
away
and that's brave in one way but in
another way it's ridiculous
so you don't want to do that right so
there's a whole bunch of things that
make for a good choice
but the point he's making here is that
you go
from habit to character
by making choices and making them well
and that's what changes you and if we
don't
make good choices it will violate our
nature
but it's not natural in the same senses
are growing
or as an oak tree growing is natural
the realm of volition in which human
beings live
is all important you can take a thousand
examples they're everywhere
but if you do if you commit vicious acts
often uh abuse people
uh which will turn you into a tyrant and
you'll be hated and
unhappy drink to excess turn you into
drunk
be unhappy you can do those things
then you're harming your nature whereas
if you make good choices
you accord more completely with your
nature
but don't mistake that you are not an
agent in the doing
of it there's a lot in the ethics that's
a goldilocks
argument not too hot not too cold just
right not too hard not too soft
and that's an interesting problem right
because
how do you make a rule to tell which is
which
how do you know and the answer is
there isn't any rule that you can make
like in this case of training
it's not too hard to know that if you
run until you're exhausted and your
shins hurt and you can't run anymore
then you've run too much
and if you don't run enough and you're
exhausted when you start and you can't
keep up
you haven't trained enough take
moderation
um there isn't any iron rule
you're seeking a right amount indeed
it's the business of life to seek the
right
amount and there's all these
obstacles and temptations and confusions
that are in the way but if you think
about it
and you keep your soul in order and you
keep your direction
your attitude right then
you'll make better choices and aristotle
is saying
that's how you hone in on this and
another point to understand is
it gets easier while you go is school
easier than when you started yeah
you probably showed up wow it says awful
can't
do this now you know you can't it's just
hard
so you see what you've gained you have a
better
soul than you had before so that point
then
is don't underestimate what you know
and the whole question of choice is
going to hang on this thing
that in your heart of hearts you know
and if you choose against that
consistently
that is the only way to silence that
voice
and if you listen to that voice it will
become strong
and it will drown out everything else
that's the pro that is the specific
action
of character building that's what it
does
[Music]
i'm larry iron president of hillsdale
college you will find if you look at our
online courses that they cover the whole
range of human learning
all the high and fundamental things
everyone needs to know
they are free because we have always
wished to provide
sound learning to anyone who wishes to
have it